[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits
I'm link and I'm Rhett this week at the
round table of dim lighting we are
exploring the question is texting
ruining friendship specifically our
friendship right is texting ruin our
friendship
no I I'm not just we're not limiting
this discussion to just our friendship I
think we're I want to analyze my kids
and their friendships and how they used
not only texting I mean what broaden it
a technology we'll focus in on social
media
wow I mean the things as a dad that I
find myself start started much did I say
my selves yeah well you also said Wow
and then citizen is about being a dad
which is very appropriate wow I'm a dad
and I find myself really tackling some
some some odd issues when it comes to
social media and and what I think about
the quality of relationship you can have
when it's conducted mostly in that way
or I mean it mostly through your phone
not speaking into it but typing things
into it yeah the other way to say it but
we should start with us I think one of
the things I'm prepared to do is share
our very first text conversation know
like our first conversation is friends
over text I have it I have it on my
phone I've told you about it so you have
it on your phone you have it on my phone
as well and we're gonna share it with
you as as an opening salvo into the
world of technology texting and how it
impacts friendships yes we're good to
that and one second we do want to let
you know that we are going to be at the
end sea State Fair I want to do it like
a monster-truck announcer because you
just did Bradlee comedians
Wow dad's comedy duo
Redwing will be live at the NC State
Fair
October 12 7:30 p.m. torn arena all you
gotta do is get admission into the fair
and you can show up there do I threaten
link do their thing on stage at Jordan
marina yeah
for more details and took us to the fair
go to NC State Fair dot org what's the
name of a monster-truck Bigfoot Bigfoot
will not be present gravedigger grave
digger would not be present little
Bigfoot hello Bigfoot will be present
right link we'll be riding in on the
back of the Bigfoot alright that's it
Kieko thank you for adding some sort of
music bed of generic metal guitar type
thing just to really sell what just
happened okay yeah those were clear
we're gonna be the NC State Fair I think
that was not only clear it was very
powerful got good and you know what no
need to dwell on it well I'll do well on
in a second because just another word
about the creative associated with it
which we're developing currently all the
creative this is gonna be a freaking
bona fide concert y'all and I we're just
kind of dipping our toe it well we're
not dipping our toe in we're doing
freakin I'm going to the needy we're
doing an hour and a half show which is
music mostly music it's a concert is
it's not that it's not the tour of
mythicality okay which if you saw that
was like a theatrical precinct we are
doing the tour mythicality in in
November in the Northeast but this is a
different show this is gonna be just a
music show because I I see the future
Rhett I see I can see into 2019 I can
see that we might want to do more
concerts we'll see how it goes man well
if if it doesn't go well it stay fair
yeah we won't think about it anymore but
you will have the the smell of like cow
dung wafting in you know the right cow
dung and one nostril and like Polish
sausage and enough
yes I love the way those two things mix
yes a lot of nostalgia so I'm glad to be
going back all my family members are
hitting me up via text well I told my
parents about it and my dad said well we
haven't been to the NC State Fair since
the first year we were in North Carolina
RINs was in 1984 well my mom's husband
Lewis boy hits it's it's the highlight
of his year he goes multiple times
because I love it man it's I think it's
like two weeks he goes multiple times
just to go yeah I camp out there if they
did loud that he loves it man anyway we
have let's see I have dug up the very
first text exchanged between my good
buddy Rhett and I had to enter my code
on my phone I couldn't I couldn't do it
while I was talking now I got a day I
gotta say that was a little bit of a
deceptive teaser well there's a little
bit of a miss direction are you saying
that because this text exchange between
us happened yesterday yeah but on
Saturday okay because I can see it right
now day before yesterday but let me so
let me explain I'm gonna read this text
threat to you conversation that I
initiated and at a certain point I'll
explain why this is this is the first of
its kind but it starts with from me
I'll just read my part so this is pretty
cool and then I put a screenshot of an
Amazon review of our book into a text to
you I had and then I wrote I had never
actually gone into Amazon and read
reviews of our book and you know I just
need a little I just needed a little
warm and fuzzy feeling from the mythical
beast
Who am I kidding mm-hmm he sometimes you
just you're just sitting around looking
at your phone you're like I was actually
going on Kindle the Kindle app to like
download I wanted to start reading
another book on my Kindle right and so
when I went on there I was like you know
what I just kind of like to look at the
fact that we
have a book in there somebody do that to
remind myself I'm a published author it
just makes me I mean it made me feel
good it's like wow you know what by the
way since I'm in here it's kind of like
you going to Barnes & Noble you go don't
you ever go by this section to see if
our books in there I have kind of make
you feel like gives you a little but I
don't I don't camp out there I walk by
there briskly and make eye contact with
the book but I don't touch it I would
never be taught caught touching my own
book in public or like sitting there
waiting for someone to come up and not
an idiot I met a douchebag then I
started reading the reviews for the
first time and I was blown away with the
level with which people will not only
write about what they think of the book
but write about the connection to us
yeah well and and and so then I
screenshot one of those in send it to
you because it helped me feel when you
said this to me this is from Hammerton I
thought hmm okay
this is not compel this isn't that
unusual for you to send a message like
this this was total I would say total
usual because this is right and so I
responded with yeah I've read some of
those our rating is pretty unprecedented
for a book with that many ratings oh
yeah taco stroke the time I wrote that I
didn't expect to be reading it publicly
back to everyone I thought it was just
for me and you right we brag even
between the two of us in private
conversations but but it wasn't a brag
it was just a yeah it's kind of unusual
to have that many ratings in to be five
stars I was like it's great I mean this
is a good thing we're just celebrating
the fact that this is good that people
like the book and then I responded and
the things reviewers are writing about
their connection to us etc it's probably
the best place to go to understand our
older post-college
audience would so this is just us
working this is not anything unusual
this is not the first of its kind this
is just another moment via text where I
should be relaxing chilling out on a
Saturday afternoon but instead I'm
trying to simultaneously stroke my ego
and get some work accomplished how can
we utilize these reviews to further
understand our demographic and proper
proper you wrote that at 1:36 p.m. and
as you can see I had assumed that okay
end of conversation I do not need to
respond to this last things I
did not respond to it thought
conversations over it was an exchange of
information as is typical given our text
history and then it got weird it got new
I decided to change the subject and I
just said how was the concert last night
that's a first
that's an absolute first on our on our
text thread to ask a purely friendly
good conversation starter we do not use
texting in this way and never have never
have you may think it sounds weird but
we do not use texting and we use text to
exchange information but conversation is
like how was your day or how was the
concert last night always happen in
person okay never done it but I just
went with it okay I went with it I said
great he puts on a really good show now
I was talking about Jason Isbell and the
400 unit played at the Greek Theatre in
Los Angeles uh yeah I was invited to go
buy rhett and I I politely declined for
reasons that I'll get it and Jason is
one of my favorite artists and I've seen
him before live my wife and actually my
whole family loves him like we play the
songs all the time in the house in the
car so I brought everybody like for a
number of reasons didn't end up being
able to go but Jesse and Shepherd and I
went had a great time so and I said it
he put he puts on a really good show but
again that's not the point of this I
didn't I didn't expand beyond that
because I was like didn't seem like the
time of the place it never has been for
us before and again I do think we maybe
should before we'll read the rest of
this text there in one second but just
to clarify further we I mean text has
just been something that's been purely
for logistics like we may even go far as
to say hey let's I want to hear about
the concert like that might be something
that I would text but I wouldn't say how
was it let's have a let's have a
legitimate friendly conversation right
now it'd be like let's let's put a pin
in this until we're together when
we have when we conduct our friendship
and then we'll do that right I
I think it's how old we are you know
let's not let's not analyze it okay all
throughout let's let's get through it
see you're already bored whether you
hate it yeah how's the concert last
night great he puts on a really good
show I said I just can't get into his
driving rock songs I just like the slow
ones whereas someone like first aid kit
who were going to see soon I like all of
what they do this point I'm like this is
weird we are in a conversation that
we've never had on the phones before but
but again I don't dislike it I was also
doing nothing true I was also a nothing
at the time that's great I was sitting
somewhere in my house and I was like
okay wants to talk weird
and you said Feldman it's like very
confused I knew you would be that we
don't talk like this and I and here's
the thing and I thought I said I said
that I wasn't gonna stop and analyze it
I told you not to analyze it but now
because of his reactions I have to I
told you before this started that I
don't think is how old we are I think
it's a combination of how old we are and
how we are period because there are
other 40 year old people who text
relationally but it's but it but it is
exclusive I mean the kids do it almost
exclusively they're constantly
conducting their relationships via text
but they don't remember a time when they
didn't do that right but it's we had to
transition into it and we never did it
didn't seem right and you know an
interesting thing a reminder at the top
of this I can see your picture and look
at it this picture is the picture of you
the moment you bought your very first
iPhone and it was the moment you bought
your very first iPhone we were together
picture of you and the first thing we
did when we got our iPhones was take a
picture of each other and store our
contact information in our iPhones and
that picture has not changed you don't
even have a beard Rhett and in the
picture we're you have a chinstrap
we thought it would be a good idea if
the picture of the person of the other
person had them on the phone in their
picture
yeah so that you would be able to
picture what they look like when they
were talking to you which is on a phone
and then for it made sense to me that's
the very first picture I ever took put
in there and then four years after that
sometimes still now on a whim if I'm
entering someone into my contacts
I don't know if that's what it's called
anymore address book contacts yeah it
hasn't changed that much
I'll tell him - I'll say hold up your
phone like I'm calling you yeah and then
I'll take the pretty it's a cool thing
to do still in 2018 get where the kids
never change that photo so that's when
we first learned how to do this I mean
we were out of college we we had
children right but okay but when you
questioned the greatness of Jason Isbell
because of his driving rock songs which
i think is a a little bit of a miss kick
miss characterization
you know what I mean I said the harder
ones work well in person he's got a
really good band and now I'm on a roll
relationally I'm like ah I could see
that did you get recognized taught by
him I thought that was an interesting
way to answer to ask the question
because typically the pause the dot
indicates a pause but when you send it
all as one text it's just it just I see
it all together so but I understood what
you were implying which is hey I'm
asking you you get recognized as Rhett
from rhett and Link by him but then by
him because you know that I once tweeted
at Jason he tweeted back at me and sort
of following me one of the greatest I
got the greatest honors of my life I
didn't know that I was just making a
joke and and so I said like from stage
while he was performing he like stopped
everything and singled you out and
because we are not good at this
relational texting you can see we cross
texted in the middle of this this is the
point where yeah I didn't answer your
question I was adding to my previous
answer but it came later it came by both
came at 1:45 p.m. I said and the lyrics
the best John Mayer called him the best
lyricist today now I must say the reason
I said that is because a drunk woman
behind me said it during the concert so
I don't her word is I don't have
independent verification of that but she
was she's had a lot of things throughout
the evening and I heard all of them and
so to
Shepard oh but one thing she did say to
her dad
who she was with when heard her dad was
like ah I love his lyrics the dad was
obviously being introduced to Jason
Isbell at the concert and he was like I
just love the lyrics and she was like
John Mayer says that he's the best
lyricist of all time dad I want to do
send that to you I did but then I asked
John Mayer as a like a measuring stick
for greatness it does show our age well
because John Mayer is one of the best
lyricist of all time as well so you know
is he I think he's right
I think he's great I like I like all of
his hard songs in itself so I think that
a 4000k John Mayer is amongst the best
modern-day lyricist is that it more is
that unless sensational thing to say I
really like John Mayer he's not just
good on the guitar guys he can write a
great song I then answered the question
no didn't see him and then I Jason yes
then I talked about seeing someone that
we both know ok we'll skip the guitar
tip over this part it's it's not
important and then I said but fans so at
this point am I making this about work
again like I mean this is kind of
revealing I'm getting a little
self-conscious now it's like I'm talking
about my hot tub again I'm like I'm
trying to have a friendly conversation
with my buddy for the first time ever on
text with no agenda but we're not and
then I'm like did you get recognized
yeah yeah but you got it you gotta
contextualize this for the people
listening because when we talk about
that kind of thing we're obviously not
bragging to each other me telling you
that I got recognized is not so I can be
like hey man I got recognized again I
was legitimately furia it's a data point
for our business right cuz did we talk
about it if we both really loved Jason
Isbell you more than me because we've
established that and then you're there
and you get recognized it's like oh
people who have good taste in music also
like us
that's a good side right the Venn
diagram of good tastes but then I said
no that was in the VIP area again I'm
not bragging I'm just I'm I'm just
relating things to link here I was like
but still I might would have gone with
the VIP area or was it lame I was like
nah it was nothing same kind of thing we
did for the Morel concert at the Greek
before we knew him sounds like a couple
of douches we're horrible yeah I'm like
yeah so no fans there I'm like pressing
yeah and I was like a couple of people
got a picture like yes and then I'm like
I'm going deeper I'm gonna make a bold
choice
by this point I felt weird because I had
been sitting down texting for multiple
minutes and then just I never do this I
don't just sit down to text who kind of
freak does that right me neither
right but if we were it wouldn't be to
each other because we're so self-aware
of our like the parameters of our
relationship if we do something that's
not like something that we do in our
relationship alarms start going off it's
like oh you you started talking over
text or you helped you helped me with my
seatbelt yeah yeah yeah in the car or
why why are you helping me more you hug
me when you saw me right I mean like we
have groups of friends and all our
friends are huggers and like we see them
all the time and we hug them every time
and then I kind of go through everybody
then I see you and I'm like it's kind of
not at you yeah if I even acknowledge
you right it's kind of like seeing
yourself in the mirror is it do you hug
yourself in the mirror or do you make
eye contact briefly and then move on we
it's like a it's like we say we're like
an old married couple but even an old
married couple still hug each other
unabashedly right but I know an old
married maybe they don't know married
couple the reason why we're like an old
married couple is that we have certain
we have our protocols of relationship of
friendship and and they're set so
anything that deviates from that like
having them just a friendly text
exchange
is is is a deviation which means it's
odd which means something must be up
I was fully committed at this point I
think I think this can lead to growth in
our relationship and let's put a pin in
that I'll come we need to come back to
that thought okay yeah we need to get
through this so we can get to the
analysis Oh or at least the ad yeah I
get we got it we got to put an ad in
this podcast that's really what matters
okay where was I
subject change is what you you bet you
put it in bracket I actually put in
brackets change sign of age as well yeah
that's people don't do that I don't
think the kids know where brackets are I
said some a fan pointed out that that we
say smell of that instead of saying
smell that when we try to get the other
person to smell something you say I saw
that comment and I think it's crazy I
don't say that and I said you're saying
I say that and you said I would have
guessed it but I'm saying I don't think
I do and what I meant to say was I
wouldn't have guessed it but I am saying
that I don't think I do definitively and
I said so yes you are saying that
because you misunderstood what I was
saying and at that point I know bond no
you were saying that I did and you
didn't and that ended our conversation I
know yeah no apparently our friendship
again even though we are now
face-to-face what I'm saying is what I
meant to write was I wouldn't have
guessed that you said that
oh but instead I took a fence yeah yeah
like I took pseudo offense I thought it
was funny but I just thought you were
being belligerent well I I would have
guessed it that you said it right I
wouldn't exactly and this is the problem
with texting for relationships and okay
I know this is one of the pitfalls and I
didn't yeah I didn't even realize that
this is why the conversation ended
because what I meant to say was well I
would have never said that you would
have said it if I had to choose between
the two of us I would guess that you
were the one who said it and but I never
heard you say it that I know of and I'm
pretty sure that I've never said it now
I'm probably wrong on all counts and I
probably will get like a supercut of me
saying smell of that poster do you do
please do I want to see a supercut to
see if that's true or not because that's
a big question but there is a bigger
question which I want to say
until we explore multiple avenues in the
quality of friendship when conducted
over technology Tech's social media
across our lives our kids lives right
our friends lives and whether or not
that's good or bad or indifferent and
let's come back to this exchange oh you
want to keep coming back to it now at
the very end again see if there's any
ultimate conclusion that can we can
apply to our own friendship sure I think
that's a great idea all right okay we're
gonna get back into some of the like
personal well analyze that text exchange
at the end we're gonna get into talking
about the way that we've kind of related
to our kids and the way that they are
different than us I thought a good way
to get into this it's just some stats
you know me and the stats these stats
come from Psychology Today and relate to
using text as a form of communication
33% of adults and 77% of 18 to 22 year
olds prefer texts over all forms of
communication including in person so Wow
77 percent 18 to 22 year olds would
rather text and you can anything else
you have to and I think you can
extrapolate that and say that if you're
under 18 that number is definitely
higher than 77 percent so it's safe to
say that more than 77 percent more than
8 out of 10 kids teenagers and younger
if you've got a phone prefer texting
over all forms of communication 1/3 of
all adults prefer text to phone calls
text is the most used form of
communication for adults under age 50
and Americans send five times as many
texts as compared with phone calls each
day now just a quick side note really
because if I said you would Americans
send all at least text seventy five
percent of the world uses some type of
video chat application like Skype or
whatsapp in place of texting the
majority of users around the
world average only six minutes of
texting daily so the texting at this
rate is is a bit of a I don't say
Western phenomenon it's partly that but
it tends to be places that have had a
lot of financial success and everybody
has a smartphone but it's interesting
because a lot of these people in these
places have like India a lot of people
have smartphones and computers mmm but
they're talking to each other via video
chat and I don't know exactly I don't
know any of the reasons for why that's
the case but just an interesting tidbit
that came up in this well III think that
we're approaching this from from from a
weird place right as evidenced by our
first text exchanges friends being two
days ago
we are assimilating to something that
our kids and the rest of society as they
grow up are just growing into
instinctively so for us I think that
there's there's an exercise in and
seeing how utilizing technology and our
phones can increase the quality of our
friendships it's something that I've
been very resistant to whereas most
people and I think will younger people
or what I'm afraid of
for my kids I'll put in it up put it in
I'll couch it that way is that the
opposite extreme that if they would
prefer to text versus anything else how
much how does that how does that impact
your your relationships and not only
that your even your ability to conduct a
meaningful relationship right you know I
mean are you are they being
short-circuited by technology to to have
a lower capacity for connection but I
think we should start with our with our
own experience yeah I think for me
before I looked at the the research
which we're going to continue to get
into
you because I never really looked at
this I had just heard and also I think
just naturally inferred and assumed that
it just can't be a good thing sometimes
I have a tendency to and my wife calls
me out on this quite a bit to begin
sounding like the old grumpy old garage
a man who thinks that this generation in
fact one time my my mom told me that
when she was hanging out with Shepherd
who again at the time was like eight
years old she said Shepherd was talking
about something related to Locke and she
and he literally said this generation of
teenagers this is eight year old
speaking you can imagine where he got
that from and I'm like okay well maybe I
have been in and I don't want to be that
guy because every older generation
thinks that there are deficits in the
younger generation and the reality most
often is that yes there are deficits but
there's also areas in which they are
better more equipped for different
things and you see that as you look at
an analytic an NGO there's places online
you can go and just analyze the
different generations and like their
propensity to drug abuse and divorce and
that kind of thing and there's an ebb
and flow it's not the world isn't
contrary to popular belief every
generation isn't getting worse in the
world isn't going to hell in a
handbasket
it's a popular narrative but not true
well there's a general trick there's an
overall trajectory towards the hell in a
handbasket alright come on no we're not
there's in fact might have a couple good
years but in fact it's absolutely the
opposite on the whole but this that's
not what this podcast is about today and
I think we're trying to so in the spirit
of of that mindset I've tried to say you
know what we we've we've developed over
the over the past few years a group of
friends who we hang out together I mean
there's like there's around a dozen of
us it's kind of crazy
mmm-hmm that we've all connected in this
way that we spend a lot of time together
I'm
on any to two weeks stretch we all see
each other you know this is very unusual
in Los Angeles yeah it's awesome but
what happened was right from the
beginning
they created a text thread and added me
to it added you to it mm-hmm
and it our wives to it the kids of the
adults in the group they kind of I think
they have their own texture to I don't
know what that for sure but I think I'm
sure they have to I didn't know I was
like well and then they just start
talking on it and I've I just the first
thing I observed was just a general
attitude of well I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna do this well they
were doing things like putting memes
into the text it's like what what am i
you know a twelve-year-old and I I would
observe it from a distance and think
this is funny these are funny people
they're having a good time I'm having a
good time
and sometimes things would get more
serious and somebody would share
something that they wanted to share with
the group they were dealing with or
whatever and people would offer advice
and perspective and be like whoa whoa
whoa whoa this is like there's more than
on my phone more than like it like a
like a a mildly inappropriate jiff this
is this is some actual life stuff
happening within a text sometimes I read
majorly inappropriate yeah yeah yeah
but and so then I thought well okay I'll
warm up to it maybe I'll try it and then
I'm like trying to chime in and I find
myself absolutely parallel like not even
beginning to type and delete and I
reading that cloud that then so oh he's
type I guess which doesn't show that
this is I don't think that this is
absolutely normal I think that we're
both a little bit in the abnormal place
when it comes to this because what I did
mmm-hmm I think I think a lot of it has
to do with way that we've scheduled our
day yeah a lot of the people in the
group are super creative and there's a
don't regimen as scheduled I don't I
don't know anyone else
who has a nine-to-five like we're we're
creative this is what we do for a living
but given our you know we've got a lot
of left brain going on as well we just
naturally sort of fall into this
schedule of coming to an office and
having meetings and having a bunch of
stuff on her schedule and then going
home everything's very regimented for us
and so like social text conversations
don't fit naturally but even when we
were at home just sitting there seeing
these texts come through I early on
silent at the conversation oh yes
because you did not get the notification
cuz I would be my phone would just be
once they got going and I didn't know
how to contribute and I now let me just
I wasn't gonna get to this yet but let
me throw something in there because
there's a study that shows and I think
this is very applicable for what we're
talking about the way that we perceive
this group there's a study that shows
this is in the Journal of computers and
human behavior the study found I got
that on my coffee table this study found
that similarity and texting styles was
linked to relationship satisfaction so
texting in the same way at similar
frequencies makes people feel like their
relationships are going well now this is
this was done in the context of romantic
relationships but people analyzed how
connected they are based on if there's
symmetry and they're texting so you're
texting about the same kind of things
you're texting as often as each other
approximately yeah and so I think that
we began to perceive that because we
weren't participating in the text thread
I think I began to think that maybe they
think that I don't care about them as
much as they care about me or whatever
or I don't let this group and we ended
up talking about that as a group in
person not on the text thread but
because somebody else in the group was
like I'm sorry I don't I'm not I don't
text that's not what I do and then we
write us too sorry we think it's really
funny and we love all you guys but we
just don't we don't naturally contribute
in this way it's not normal we don't do
it with anybody it's not just you it's
me
yeah so we felt self-conscious but I did
notice even though I was lurking I felt
so much more connected to that to the
group
and I mean with with 12 other people I
mean there's still like five that do
most of the texting but and so I started
to soften to it a little bit I said to
fast-forward over a year later I still
don't text that often yeah
but but I appreciate it so much more as
a legitimate form of connection and then
recently I think we we experienced the
limit of that you know cuz we got we got
we got into some stuff right and I think
I have a I'm gonna I'm gonna go back
into some data which I think informs
okay what happened and then what
happened again up top in our
conversation cuz I started to get really
hopeful I'm like man it's like we don't
see we try to see each other every week
but if we don't we've got this cut we
got this thread it's like literally it's
it's you can it's a constant thing that
keeps going thread of connection is that
why they call it a thread yep Wow
you just figured it out you just crack
the code I just did it okay so what's
the problem what are the pitfalls well
and where do they stem from according to
UCLA professor Albert Mehrabian great
guy weird mustache probably pronouncing
that wrong
Albert you know dr. Albert I think
you're saying Albert correctly during
face-to-face conversation humans this is
this is the percentage of different
factors that you are relying on for
communication when you are to having a
face-to-face conversation to homosapians
talking to each other
58 percent of the communication is in
the body language
over half 35 percent is through vocal
tone pitch and emphasis that leaves
seven percent for content of message
ouch
okay so let me just say that again in
case you didn't understand when you're
talking to someone and you're
communicating to them what they're if
they're picking up what you're laying
down
it is based on 58% body language 35%
vocal tone pitch and emphasis the way
that you're speaking and 7% content of
message now Albert I don't know you I'm
not you know you may not be omniscient
and this may not be exactly 100% true
but I think that the the gist is
definitely true you know what I'm saying
it's like how do you break down
communication what was the nature
already what I'm basically saying though
is that a small percentage potentially
7% but definitely a minority of what
you're communicating to someone is
related to what you're the words coming
out of your mouth because we're animals
right you know it's we've we've
developed we've evolved in an in an
interactive and our communication our
communication with each other was way
more about all this 58% and 35% the 93%
of communication was the basis of
communication before humans of all the
ability to speak so you were I can
communicate a lot I can go into my
monster-truck voice if you want me to
but I tend to think that I was my my
ancestors okay distant were they were it
was more like meowing and purring it was
gentler cats cat-like okay don't believe
that that's how the evolutionary tree
breaks down but whatever but the B is my
spirit animal the point is we're at a
place where we still listen guys
biologically speaking we haven't changed
much in a couple hundred thousand years
so it's severely handicapping our
ability to communicate well when you
limit it to that whatever we're sent
funneling and that's not even including
spellcheck we are funneling the breath
of human communication into this tiny
little slit that is 7% of our
communication capabilities meaning that
all these things that serve as visual
and auditory signals to help you
actually understand what people are
saying
is completely not present when you're
sending a text message and so when you
start to get into things just to go back
to the story yeah what with our friend
group we start I mean I'm not gonna get
in I'm not gonna dish dirt on what we
had to deal with but it was the type of
thing that there were concerns there was
emotions involved there was it was it
was heated though there were there was a
couple of argument but it was different
perspectives they came an argument so
there was a couple of things that were
misunderstood a couple of things that
were said and a few times people kind of
pitched in and said shouldn't we just
talk about this in person those people
who kind of wanted to bail on the text
thread I even sent that text at one
point and was like can we just talk
about this in person now we did end up
getting together and talking through
some of the things that were texted and
I ultimately think that the combination
of the two things was good but I don't
want to I don't want to come to that
conclusion yet I want to I don't want to
get there yet because I think right now
what we're exploring is the inadequacy
of text only communication in
relationships and friendships I think it
always ups I'm not trying to get into
the details of the story which which
we're not are not appropriate to go into
here so we're not gonna do that but the
only point I'm making is I experienced
firsthand pushing the deepest connection
and with the with the heart and the mind
via text and just hitting a wall and
saying all right we have to we have to
get together to finish this conversation
this can't happen it digitally right you
know so I mean we explored the we
explored the depths of it well we kind
of went through what I think is
ultimately and it's kind of what just
happened with us at the beginning of
this is what we would kind of prescribe
as the method of using text and
face-to-face conversation in conjunction
let's wait
- totally land that plane because I
think that when I think about my kids
and when I was looking at this research
was like I kind of feel like I should
talk to my kids about this because I
would have never I knew that that all
these visual and auditory cues were
things that were huge in communication
but I'm also not necessarily text
texting on my phone but text-based
communication email is something that I
believe in in fact a lot of times even
though I can engage in a conversation I
can usually get my thoughts across in a
pretty compelling way
I prefer many times to type things out
because you have a chance to kind of
Center yourself and move through the
information that the the pace that you
want without interruption without having
to justify things as you go but when you
when you do it a vocal exchange or
somebody a vocal exchange or verbal
exchange but ionically am doing it right
now
the the research suggests that
text-based relationships
texting in the context of a relationship
can give you the illusion of closeness
but it actually is decreasing relational
stability and satisfaction because you
feel like it makes it worse yes so there
is a risk that if you are relying
primarily on textual communication in a
relationship you are creating a false
sense of intimacy and closeness but
because that 93% of yourself that this
person would be getting if it was a
face-to-face conversation is not is not
present you alternately and again this
is this is based on like a bunch of
studies kind of together analyzed and
people come into conclusions about those
is that it makes you feel like you're
connected but ultimately you if you're
not actually having face-to-face
connection you you're not nearly as
close as you perceive and I think the
same thing I think is ultimately true in
friendships but it kind of is really
really it's exacerbated in the context
of a romantic relationship I mean I do
obviously there are many successful in
the real world romantic relationships
that started or
I mean even continued for long periods
of time that were just like text-based
penpal based yeah you know and I don't
want Adam in it I'm not trying to
diminish that I'm just saying I thought
risk I would I would venture to guess
that anyone who has a successful
relationship in the real world that's
that went through just text for a long
time they at when they added that
component of actually being in the same
space you know having the the complete
ability to communicate that that added a
facet to the relationship that they
would not prefer to give up and it may
actually make or break a relationship
you know I'm saying so you may be like
this kind of seemed to work again I
think this happens all the time you
start an online relationship with
somebody you think there's an incredible
connection because again it creates a
connection that's very isolated and
funneled down to this one sort of form
of communication and it doesn't mean
that other parts of your brain are not
involved in terms of the way that you're
responding there you you know when you
get a text from somebody there's a
dopamine rush and you get into this
dopamine loop or you're waiting to have
somebody react and yeah Fellman
catfishing is is a great example of the
that's the prime example of you think
you've got a connection with somebody
and then you found out you got catfished
but even sort of short of that and what
happens with that by the way it's when
like you you meet a girl online and it's
really just a big dude in his basement
who's catfishing you but for what to get
money from you to just get off on it
there's multiple reasons that somebody
would do that how would they get money
from you
hey you ever get we've got this
connection but I really need braces oh
but you don't okay send me $3,000 I can
get braces but you never meet in person
that's kind of my point where I was
going was when you do meet in person and
it's just a big dude in his basement
it doesn't have the same effect as if it
was like a hot girl without braces well
but his teeth are straight right
yeah yeah when a host of catfish okay it
is showing him TV you should watch oh I
don't have that face so but what I'm
talking about it's not catfishing but
just like oh we had this connection and
this can happen in the contest of an
already existent relationship right you
could be like you were in Brazil for a
month and we communicated via text and
it seemed like we were so close and then
you showed up and it was like there's
nothing there in person can you go back
to Brazil so we can text again there's
something happening in your brain you're
rewarding yourself for this
communication but are you really
connecting and let's bring it back to
friendship and our kids I think the
thing that I'm that I'm concerned about
is that you you have these shallow
friendships that are just it's captioned
based conversations you know it's like a
little blip blip blip blip here I mean I
don't I don't look at the specifics of
their conversations we I talk to my kids
about the conversations that they're
having and there's you know we've tried
to have a level of openness there but I
just get concerned that again as we
experienced you can only have you can
only really care for somebody so much
even if it's a lot over text as a friend
so I'm not talking about man tickly I
just think that it being able to on one
hand tell the difference between who's
an acquaintance and who's an actual
friend who's somebody who's gonna be
there for you you know that's I mean
that's why the friends theme song is the
way it is because that's what a friend
is men are for you man I'm not not out I
will text you Yeah right be different
I'll be there for you right shallow I'll
send a meme to you versus deep it's the
difference between like getting along
with people like Oh like we have fun
texting each other the means mmm the
mean things well or versus being
connected I mean there's a certain level
of
once you really get in get in it with
somebody like as a true friend you're
gonna have conflict you're gonna have
you're gonna have problems I mean we're
to have love like friendly love not
romantic love really love have that
friendly love I mean you're gonna
there's a whole slew of problems and
challenges that come along with that
that are easily avoidable if you just
keep the conversation shallower and
text-based and it's an illusion well the
reason we do it is because it's super
convenient and easy it's much easier
sure it's on my terms it's on my time
and I can say what I want to and I don't
have to see your immediate reaction it's
so tempting to reduce a relationship to
a text base exchange because it is so
convenient and easy and that's why
that's why we do it you know what it's
not going away and we're not saying that
it should go away and because of the the
plasticity of our brains especially the
brains of our kids again with the
research studies are showing that their
brains are adapting to this level of
communication and their brains are parts
of their brains that kind of connect
their thoughts to their this is their
thumbs and their index fingers and
they're basically the the part of their
brain that controls that fine motor
skills they're they are adapting and
becoming better at it and they're better
at it than we will ever be because
they're neuroplasticity is way higher
it's not gonna go away they're gonna
keep doing it and I think that there are
positives to use the analogy that
another guy in psychology today Zak
Carter used he talked about a cake and
he was like building a relationship out
of text is like having a cake that is
icing only so it may look and feel like
a cake but when you kind of go into it
there's no there's less substance and
there's no where's the cake
whereas there I don't personally and I
know you don't like I don't like cake
without icing right it adds some some
moisture to the whole thing and so I
think I do think that if texting is like
a lot ice okay but I don't ya know just
to write them out right and so but you
want to have
cake you want to have a real foundation
for a relationship and that is actually
your contact and your real face-to-face
conversations and your quality time that
you spend with each other but then the
icing on the cake that makes the cake
even better and makes a cake what it is
at least in the context of modern
society is text-based communication
because I think ultimately what happens
you want to punch of just constant
contact or more frequent contact because
we've experienced it keeps it alive it
keeps it vibrant yeah in between those
moments of connecting in person because
we have actually benefited from this
text thread that we have amongst our
friends oh yeah and even the situation
that we just brought up we would have
never gotten together and talked with
everybody in the time frame which we did
if it was if it weren't for the rated
that text thread right so to me I died I
think that there is a healthy balance
between the two but first of all you
can't blame anybody who says I'm not
gonna text at all and I'm just gonna
have a complete face-to-face
conversation it's a little Luddite ish
but oh I think that ultimately where you
could go very wrong is if you begin to
conduct your relationships exclusively
on text and what I think that the kids
are doing in this generation this
generation of teenagers they're
beginning and ending romantic
relationships via text they're breaking
up via text they're asking to go out via
text they're saying will you go to the
prom with me via text that is an
imbalance and I gotta say listen I know
it's easy but the it's too easy it's too
convenient it's too narrow it's not
broad it's not relying on who you are as
a person is relying on 7% of who you are
communicating to 7% of who someone else
is it's not a 100 percent to 100 percent
connection so you really you're really
only breaking up with 7 percent of the
earth if you broke up with somebody via
text you're still 93 percent in a
relationship with them that's a fact
science says it deal with it I'll give a
meme to you
yeah so I I hope to help my kids begin
to understand that texting and your the
phone in general is just a tool that you
can you can abuse it in so many ways of
course but when it comes to
relationships as a throme on God and you
know the gorilla gorilla glass will hold
up God and know that it's not it it
can't be the the center the cakey center
of your friendships I mean if you want
to build real friendships of which
you're fortunate to have two or two five
close friends by the way I was reading
that
studies show that you really can't have
more than 150 friends at any level
mm-hmm like an acquaintance level that's
like because that was the size of
communities of our ancestors it's a
brain thing yeah I say it's a brain
capacity thing that actually be friends
once you get above that once communities
and you know ancient communities got
above about a hundred and fifty people
the group dynamics began to break down
and they had to break up and become new
groups and so now what we have are you
have those active friends which there
may be like five close friends then like
fifteen at the next layer and like the
layers go out of how connected you
actually are to them to where you get to
a point where well you've got dormant
friends who you can reconnect with if
you happen to be in the same town but
you don't live there anymore you
visiting and then you've got all across
Facebook if you're into that
commemorative friends like oh I I went I
went to I went to summer camp with that
person and now we're just like they're
just floating out here as a
commemorative complementing each other's
babies but I you know I I think that
ultimately using the tools properly our
kids can be but you know there's a level
of connection that they can have that we
didn't experience and to get back to us
that I think there's an opportunity for
us you know I think
maybe we can find ourselves I'm just
gonna throw that out there having a
conversation over text and just as if I
think it's a great show I think for us
it's definitely a great thing I think it
will only enhance things because one of
the things I find that if there's an
issue that I need to deal with I
I often and this may be a little bit it
may be cowardly if I there's a situation
where there's some conflict I typically
like to send an opening written
communication as sort of a thesis of
like these are some things that I want
to explore but this is not the end of
the conversation I'm not expecting
textual communication back it's like
this is like my opening salvo and now
let's talk about it I think a
combination of text communication and
face-to-face communication can be a
great way to get through conflict and
you know what I conduct a relationship I
Christina actually did that last week I
I totally forgot about it within the
context of this conversation that you
know weird we're dealing with something
and you know she she's got we're
separated you know I'm here she's there
and she's talking about okay this is
what I'm going through these are
thoughts that are going through my mind
based on the conversation we had last
night I'm not gonna call it an argument
but it was it was just a conversation
and spicy one it was great because you
know we had to put a pin in things we we
slept on it and then I had to go to work
but then she sent me a tech I sent her a
text I was like I look forward to
continuing our conversation you know and
she actually she like wrote out - I was
like whoa two paragraphs she had it
locked and loaded in the Notes app and
just copy and pasted it and it was ready
for you detects I mean it was difficult
to get that in the middle of the day but
ultimately it was better than not
getting it because I could like on the
drive home I like reflected on her
thoughts so then we were that much
further along when we sat down and had
the rest of the conversation which still
was like okay two hours of focused let's
continue this conversation this is the
work of marriage
would have you know we wouldn't have
gotten nearly that far if it wasn't for
that that preamble that she swell and
sometimes okay being able to communicate
when you're not together we've never
twit - I mean that's that's what is out
of this friend group - just toss that in
there because I think we're all learning
that well Joe I was Jesse and I have
done exactly what you were talking about
and we did it before the friend group
there's been a couple of times where we
do have an argument and yeah we go to
sleep and we wake up and we're either
the communication climate is a little
cold if you will and then at some point
during the day someone will instigate a
text conversation that is an apology or
an explanation and again it isn't for
the purposes of solving the conflict a
reconciling via text but sometimes when
you're not in each other's presence and
you've had time to cool off and you're
not just sitting there across in the
person that the last time you were with
them you were arguing with them you get
this text and you can process it and in
your own world in the privacy of your
own thoughts and I think it does set up
it's an opening volley that gives you
the opportunity to then go and take the
conflict and address it face to face I
do think that it's very helpful very
purposeful yeah and that's deep work I
mean that's like I said that is the work
of marriage or of a relationship and can
obviously be applied to friendships but
I think for us let's start simple let's
just start with a few memes memes does
mean time I think I think we can search
in that thing and find ourselves yeah
I've done it you want me to send you
gifs of you and you send me gifts of me
no I want I want you to be you and me be
me let's go Munich eight to each other
you see only gifs man we are really
we're completing the loop of douchey
yeah the do salute the diffuse loop
round in the turn on the booze flip
hello
currently in my hot tub sending sending
gifs of myself to my friend Rhett from
one douche to another in his hot
now one thing I will say that we didn't
talk about we hinted at it a little bit
earlier when we're talking about the way
the rest of the world communicates I
don't know what the research indicates
on video chats mmm-hmm I have noticed
now my kids don't do this but I have
seen the teens talking to each other
Lincoln uses house party video chat is
is very common and I don't know again I
don't know what the dad I don't know how
many people are doing it doing his
homework he's got his phone propped up
on his desk
yeah but again I I don't know what the
percentages are but at that point you
are getting body language and you are
getting voice tone and emphasis you're
getting a very large percentage you're
just not getting smelling breath which
might be great you know because if
somebody's got halitosis that kind of
becomes 100 percent of what you're
thinking about yeah so there's a way to
take that out of the equation so anyway
maybe that's one of the great things
about video chat and I'm assuming at
some point they keep talking about it
and they keep saying it's gonna happen
holograms man but holograms will be able
to perfectly capture what you're trying
to communicate not perfectly I'm sure
well you know almost perfectly it'll be
glitches your heroes they be glitches in
like a a knot will be removed and then
the whole meaning of what you're saying
will change cuz he left out the neg
right good that could happen but thirty
years from now I think people will be
breaking up with Holograms and that will
count I think that'll be an official
breakup if you break up via hologram I
don't want to beat a dead horse but I'm
having second thoughts about this mean
you like texting as friends let's back
off a memes because that was just me
being stupid mm-hmm but I don't know man
I think like if there's a third person
we can do it like when Mike from back in
North Carolina Texas that he went and he
took a dump in the Trader Joe's and then
he comes out he's washing his hands and
then a woman walks in and it was she's
in the wrong
and trader Jan's right and we we laugh
that up and we each set a little funny
thing in response you want to get Mike
and on a texture just so we don't feel
weird about memeing each other I think
we'll just turn him into a third douche
is honestly what I think will happen
I think douche spritz I think it's
contagious
I think douchery is contagious scene I
think what call it that I mean that's
that undermines everything we're saying
can we put that on the t-shirt can we
sell that douchery is contagious we'll
sell it on the dark web douche loop
I like douche loop better yeah we'll put
that in the dark
mythical dot store slash dark web to the
dark web but we can't cat we can't
characterize us having a friendly text
exchange is being douchey it's only
douchey when we're talking about
ourselves in like a self-absorbed way I
mean but just having a talk having a
text but you did just we just talk it's
not we're not being douches but you did
just realize like three weeks ago that
your phone was waterproof so you could
be texting from the hot tub I'm just
saying I mean it you could actually it
sometimes sometimes just for kicks I've
got my Bluetooth music going and I just
put my phone under the surface of the
hot tub just a little goal the music
goes away and then I bring it back up
just to experience technology i what
yeah once you told me that my phone was
waterproof leaks had two generations of
iphone that were waterproof and didn't
know it until we were in in Fiji
speaking of douche bags we were the most
self aware of podcasts we were
snorkeling in Fiji and I had my phone
out no it was when I was I was uh I was
videoing you guys my kids and your kids
and you on the banana boat being pulled
behind yeah the thing and you were like
hey phones waterproof I was like yes so
was your got the same phone and you does
it in the Bible and I couldn't believe
it
so then yeah actually last week my my
family was all outside in the hot tub
mm-hmm
and I wasn't outside I came outside and
I had I had my phone in my hand and I am
I jumped in my jumped in to delve in the
pool and then I swam up to where they
were and I pulled up my phone and acted
like I was talking on it cuz I thought
that would be cool
yeah yeah it would've been cool in like
2015 and then and then Lily was like dad
you just you you just don't with your
glasses on your glasses are at the
bottom of the pool dad move ahead big
Wow dad I had to swim down there and
retrieve my no you're scared to go into
the bottom of the pool so man who knew
that our Soviet films you in the bottom
could go to another level panicking
because we're gonna text each other I am
so excited for us right yep
so I don't know what the moral of the
story is I guess it's some combination
of texting and face-to-face
communication is the basis of true
friendship and romantic relationships
don't text too much don't text too
literally the next two little don't do
that you want to be in you want to be in
the Goldilocks region when it comes to
texting and face-to-face contact so let
us know what you think join the
conversation use hashtag ear biscuits
wherever hashtags are used and we'll
continue the conversation I enjoy hello
let me text you some rice I can make our
bark
okay bye
[Music]